monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
ce soir vise à valider l'augmentation du
nombre de conseillers de l'assemblée de
guyane et décider de la répartition par
section ce texte déposé par les nike
adam députée de guyane n'entraîne aucune
modification du mode de scrutin des
élections de la collectivité
territoriales de guyane mais il
permettra une meilleure représentation
de la population au sein de cette
collectivité il répond d'ailleurs aux
dispositions déjà prévues par le code
électoral
je tiens d'abord à remercier l'excellent
travail fourni par les rapporteurs des
deux chambres
je remercie particulièrement notre
collègue rapporteure catherine belrhiti
qu'a bien voulu nous auditionnée elle a
su saisir deux points qui me semble
essentiel d'une part le consensus de
toute la classe politique guyanaise sur
les objectifs poursuivis par cette
proposition de loi
d'autre part par la nécessité d'une
adoption rapide pour une promulgation de
la loi avant le 31 décembre 2020
condition indispensable pour que les
élections de la city jet et bien lieu au
cours de l'année 2021 à l'instar des
élections régionales départementales
ainsi cette proposition de loi prévoit
la répartition du nombre de sièges par
section le nombre de sièges octroyée au
titre de la prime majoritaire et la
répartition par section de ces derniers
devront être déterminées en application
des règles énoncées par la loi par un
arrêté préfectoral pris au plus tard le
15 janvier de l'année du renouvellement
de l'assemblée de guyane madame la
rapporteure et mes collègues ont su
préciser les dispositions de cette
proposition de loi et l'excellent
travail de coordination entre nos deux
assemblées
donc je me permettrai monsieur le
ministre d'être le porte-voix de mes
collègues guyanais sur un autre sujet
qui nécessite toute notre attention
le texte qui nous réunit ici aujourd'hui
trouve sa source dans l'évolution
démographique de la population guyanaise
comme vous le savez en guyane la
démographie galopante la guyane et après
mayotte le département français où le
taux de natalité le plus élevé le taux
de mortalité le plus faible
à ces éléments s'ajoute une pression
migratoire constante est de plus en plus
prégnante
la compilation de ces phénomènes nous
pousse un taux à interroger les chiffres
du recensement effectué par les services
de l'état
comment expliquer aux guyanais qui voit
pousser des bidonvilles et des squats
sur les terrains vagues et dans les
maisons abandonnées que nous n'avons
toujours pas franchi la barre des 300
mille habitants sur ce territoire aussi
vaste que le portugal
comment expliquer à mes compatriotes
qu'avec nos 290 1000 habitants nous
produisons autant d'échecs de 300000
nantais alors que notre système de
collecte est malheureusement défaillant
voire inexistant sur une large partie du
territoire
l'ancien maire de la ville de gan que je
suis plus que convaincu que les chiffres
de la population guyane sont largement
sous-estimés
je dis bien largement sous-estimé dans
leur rapport visant à soutenir les
communes des départements et régions
d'outre-mer
mon collègue sénateur georges patient et
le député jean-rené cazeneuve ont
souligné dans leur recommandation numéro
5 la question générale des difficultés
de recensement rencontrées dans certains
territoires ultramarins et la guyane ont
fait partie en guyane l'organisation du
recensement de la population s'appuie
sur les mêmes textes réglementaires que
pour le reste de la france
les collectes sont exhaustive tous les
cinq ans pour les communes de moins de
10000 habitants et annuels sur la base
de 8% des logements pour les communes de
plus de 10 mille habitants mais l'insee
et les communes doivent s'adapter
davantage pour effectuer des collectes
plus précise et en cohérence avec les
particularités du yanez je pense à la
collecte dans l'habitat informel dans
les zones d'habitat ou les naissances
sont très rapides comme en bord de
fleuve et dans les zones d'orpaillage
illégal
malgré les efforts des uns et des autres
nous sommes encore loin du compte
et cette sous-estimation de la
population implique d'autres
conséquences
je rappelle que l'état se base sur ces
chiffres pour calculer entre autres la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
certes la dgf est en progression en
guyane mais elle demeure l'une des plus
faibles de l'ensemble des collectivités
ultramarines
cette dotation est le premier le
principal contributeur du budget des
communes de guyane compte tenu de la
faiblesse des ressources fiscales
les budgets des collectivités de guyane
peuvent se voir amputer de dotation
fait d'une évidente sous-estimation de
la population qui rappelons le sert de
base au calcul de la dg par ailleurs
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de rappeler dans
cet hémicycle la situation des écoles de
guyane qui ne peuvent pas scolarisés
l'ensemble des enfants qui se présentent
à leur porte
ce qui pose un véritable problème dans
un territoire où nombre de jeunes se
trouvent en déshérence
nous ne pouvons pas offrir suffisamment
de logements aux habitants de notre
territoire notamment les plus pauvres
monsieur le ministre je profite de ce
texte sur la guyane pour formuler un
souhait que l'état et ses services
déconcentrés assure recensement plus
efficaces et précis de la population de
guyane nous savons pouvoir compter sur
les engagements du gouvernement
en outre le groupe r d pivotera bien
évidemment pour ce texte essentiel à la
vie démocratique en guyane je vous
remercie de leur écoute